In this section of our course, we will be looking at advanced use case scenarios where
DNA calibration has been used to make changes to the metahuman head and body.
We will have a look at the scripts that were demonstrated at the 2023 UnrealFest DNA calibration
deep dive, and then we will look at the modified version of the UnrealFest script and the custom
body integration workflow that were used for the stylized atomic savage character.
So let's begin with the UnrealFest DNA calibration scripts.
The 2023 UnrealFest DNA calibration deep dive presentation, delivered by part of the three-lateral
team, demonstrated what can be achieved with the DNA calibration library.
Each piece of code from the calibration and scale script was explained in great detail,
and all of the steps for bringing in the modified DNA file and head LOD-FBX files into Unreal
Engine were shown.
These scripts allow the user to edit the neutral pose and scale the entire rig.
They contain a combination of commands that allow users to transfer details from a provided
model, snap surface joints to their new vertex positions, change the animated map setup, scale
the body and the head, update the metahuman DNA file, and export the head LODs with material
placeholders.
If you have not seen this presentation, I highly recommend you watch it and practice
using those scripts and the provided assets.
I have included a link to the presentation in the resources section of this course.
Now let's take a look at the scripts that were used for the stylized atomic savage character.
The stylized atomic savage character's body and facial features went beyond the standard
metahuman template.
The first script called atomic sDNA-calibe that was used is a modified version of the
Unreal Fest calibration script.
This version of the script transfers details from the fitted head geometry models to the
neutral pose and updates the DNA file.
The DNA file that was generated from that script was used with the custom body integration
script to merge the head with the custom metahuman body for a seamless integration.
The custom body workflow aligns the head and body skeletons.
It eliminates any seam issues that may occur during deformations, and it saves those changes
to a new DNA file.
This workflow uses multiple scripts and commands that are executed through a single script.
We will be using both of these scripts, and as mentioned, these scripts and their associated
assets are located in the source files folder of this course.
Now that we have looked at what the Unreal Fest script allows users to achieve along
with the two scripts that were used with atomic savage, let's move on to the next section
of our course where we will explore all of the steps for taking atomic savage from an
initial concept to a finalized metahuman character.